[Musique]
c'est santé c'est tout légume on ne m'a
cru un jour on les manches guillet
sauter
bouilly on le mange beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup au mexique les cactus que le
chef maria chaves affectionne pousse
dans les climats arides ou semi arides
ce sont les populations d'amérique
latine qui ont implanté des premiers
dans leur cuisine donc ça peut devenir
un aliment de subsistance linda colette
a oeuvré au sein de l'aef à eau cet
organisme de l'onu pour l'alimentation
et l'agriculture
considère que le cactus nopal aussi
nommé figuiers de barbarie peut être
salvateur pour les populations qui
vivent des sécheresses en fait la fao
dit vous avez devant vous un cactus qui
peut être cultivée dans un environnement
très aride puis que des valeurs
nutritionnelles très intéressant cette
plante là elle le casse dans plusieurs
catégories la catégorie
changement climatique biodiversité
apparent nos nutritionnistes
terrain là et fao s'intéresse aux cactus
depuis plus de 25 ans avec les
changements climatiques et la
désertification des sols l'organisme
tombe d'en promouvoir la culture
dans les pays en voie de développement
où il va y avoir la plus grande
croissance de population notamment et
c'est souvent en milieu aride donc cette
plante l'on peut aider à passer à
travers
des moments très difficiles quand il
s'agit de l'alimentation
au mexique sa consommation atteint 6,4
kg par an par habitant cet aliment fait
partie du quotidien à tel point qu'il
apparaît même sur le drapeau
moi j'adore j'adore j'adore ça j'ai tout
fait pour la voir une si j'ai commencé
j'ai les toronto la chercher j'ai acheté
beaucoup il fallait tout nettoyer tout
comme les jeux le conflit menace de plus
en plus je vais juste chez son grossiste
ici il ya un an
[Musique]
les raquettes de ne pas le frêche sont
maintenant offertes dans les épiceries
latino américaine elles sont aussi
disponibles en escabèche en ce mur ou
emballées sous vide mais pourquoi les
cactus malgré tous ces avantages
demeure-t-il si peu consommé ici au
mexique et une légumes comme n'importe
quel autre légume et sur les jeunes
connaissent pas qu'on ne se - le
consommateur va pas aller vers quelque
chose sans qu'on lui dise comment manger
comment l'apprécier puis aussi un bagage
qui est associé à unanimement l'apport
nutritionnel du cactus nopal est
intéressant riches en vitamines en
protéines et en fibres il donne aussi
une sensation de satiété donc ça ça
remplit lestement aussi puis à
semble-t-il selon certaines études quand
c'est dans l'alimentation de bétail ça
aide au niveau de la réduction des gaz
de méthane pour les ruminants
le nopal est le plus utilisé des cactus
à des fins culinaires récoltés pour ces
délicieux fruits rouges ces figues et
ses jeunes pousses mais qui dit cactus
dit épine faut savoir comment les
manipuler
or il faut juste pas toucher les petits
points ici il ya le lépine il faut lui
enlever le style comme ça je me suis
habitué mais même si son habituel mais
c'est pas évident ça prend l'expérience
du
pdj un coup de coeur sur le jus la base
et cactus
voulait me prendre par les sentiments
avec l'acidité de leurs anges pour la
petite amertume sketch c'est vraiment
très bon
pour les souks gourguen et cactus on
fait d'abord revenir oignons tomates et
coriandre mais c'était super facile à
préparer il ya beaucoup d'ingrédients
que l'autobus au mexique est ici plus qu
on s apprête différemment on mélange le
tout aux gourganes cuite et on ajoute du
cactus
dumas déménager
pour préparer le sanwi du cactus fromage
il faut d'abord poêler les raquettes
comme engrais chimiques
[Musique]
ici nous avons la salade cactus c'est
les plats les plus connus ici au
restaurant et nous savons aussi les
côtelettes de porc sauce vert et cactus
ça faisait un petit peu épicée mais
c'est très délicieux aussi qu'il ya des
gens qui aiment pas le cactus à cause de
la texture qu'est ce qu'il reste de
textes sur le ceva but c'est bis q sais
c'est que les gens n'aiment pas mais
comme celui-là c'est préparer mais tu te
laissant penser c'est très bon sopi de
ça donne la texture qu'on aurait avec
une soupe aux pois legris cheese mexique
est maintenant avec fromage panne est là
mais il ya vraiment
mais c'est pas très goûteuse non plus
c'est pas le goût qui est envahissant
non non non la salade maintenant s'il
pleut le plus populaire oui je comprends
le qualificatif le plus précis que l'on
voit baisser mais cactus c'est vrai
le plaidoyer de la f1 au à l'effet que
le cactus et la plante de l'avenir nous
fera t-il changé nos habitudes
alimentaires
au
québec on y 2 devra paterson
[Musique]